je m'appelle monsieur greu ma chaîne
parle de votre vie numérique
je vous présente toutes les nouveautés
high-tech les nouveaux produits alice
des tests des comparatifs je présente
également les nouvelles start-up de
l'high-tech française pourrait changer
votre vie demain mais je parle également
de votre stratégie
youtube vous donne des conseils pour
réussir sur youtube pour mieux crabe au
titre améliorer votre référencement
monétiser le tchad
je suis également des évaluations
devauchelle des études de cas concrets
qui vous permet de voir ce qui marche ce
qui marche pas et surtout comment
l'améliorer et partager avec vous mes
voyages mes découvertes au travers de
blogs
[Musique]
je vous invite à vous abonner à la
chaîne pour réussir votre vie numérique
tout savoir sur la high tech et réussir
votre stratégie youtube marqué mon
commentaire les choses dont vous avez
besoin que ce soit sur de l'high-tech
pour la découverte produits d'espèces
des comparatifs mais également pour
votre stratégie youtube merci
et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
[Musique]